KILLED MORE TH 800,000 PEOPLE
IN THE U.S.
AND THISANUARY 6th,
OF THE DEADLY ATTACK ON THU.S.
HENATION REMAINS BITRLY DIVIDED
T  A YEAR AGA BRAND NEW POLL F"
WASHINGTON POST" AND THE
UNIVTYF MARYLAND SHOWS 92% BELIO
FOR THE ATCKCACOMPO JUSTANS.
THE POLL ALSO SHOWS THAT I
THREE W BEEVINST GOVERNMEN
CAN ATE RG
O DECADELING CONGRESS, JANUA 6
ITPTIN
CKONING, INVESTIGATING TO E WHA
ISSIPPI, THE OF THE HOUSE SELECT
THK R JO, PPY NEW YEARO YOU.
THENABLE TO DETERMIN
NT AND
IN AACTIALLY
THHA NEW YEAR.MEHAT WHAT WE HAVE
WE CAME PERILO TO  DEMOCRACY A M
HAD THOSSUT.
WE ARE CERTAIN
HAD, HAD IT
VE ANDL
INBEINY
TNWE WIN
SITUATION.
TEE WERETHEM ANDAND BE HEARDMP
WIN OF
IEWINGIT
THOUSF GE
Y OCRRNOW, THAT'ARGE
COMMITTEEO
I CAN IGMISSTEPSWHETHER OR NOT F
A BROAD PLAN'S WHA'RTHERGSIN TEO
E DERTDEFENSAND NATIONAL GUAEEAA
EN EXCEL JENCI SVE BEEN, AND S
WORK THAT OUR COMMITTEE IS DOING
S                DAILY. FER
PRESIDENT UMTACK
YOU HAVETIMONY INDIC HE WAS WATO
COGE HD TOEVJANUARY 6th TELLINGI
US MORE WHAT AR HE WA
>> WELL, PART T
TRYING TO GET ASEE NCH IE
WHAT .T PR FROM HAVINGO IT.BID
IVAPPLY.DOES NOT
EEN TWATHAS
SUPREME COURT NOW.L AND WE TL D
TES OFTE TID U
SEEING THEAP
SOG WITHHAE NE TO FIND OUTLLO
ERF O  LACON ONUARY 6th MAY RAM
>>I CAN SAIS
ITL
TO'SOINTISUSUAL FOR ANYONE
HA
WHAT'S GOING ONG.
TO GET ALLNFORMATIT  T
COMMITTEULE
RTMENT OF JUE,AT.
UR MEMBERS O
T.F , IF THERE'S ANYTH OCO SOMEA
KE THE LET M QUESTABDENT AND
ATINAS THE C WASER ATT
I KNOW YOU'RE STILS OKPLT KNOWO
YES,  HT DO
WE HAVGNIFICANT TESTIMONY
THAT L BELIEVET
WHUSD BEEN SOMETHING.
WANT TO VY ALEN WE PRODUCE OURE
HAVPPEMLV DANA,O BE NEST WITH U
THE WORLD AND WE WANT TO ME
THE COMMITTEE'S BODY ONGR E FOR?
>> WELL,T HEPICALD TRUMP ERANDI.
HE SUES.S TO C.
TRIESO
IF HE CONTINUES TOE SUSF
WE HAVE SST WE VE TCCESS TO RECO
PR
RDS NECESSARY
FOR USVECEHEE VEO RDS, FORMER W
RMREFORETHE  IA IEF, HE ISHA
COMMTHOUS CR
CNGMA "MOCKERY"
LEUT Y? YOU KNOW, HE MAKES TWCAV
THEN HE SAYS WEL DHA
ON
DENT TRUMP CT BOTH
ONGRES  A LEGISLATIVE  TFF
OBLIGATED AS OF CONGRESTOE THE
NOW, A TO TH
DEPARTNTTO
DETEINHER ORHIAK
REFERRALS HAS NOTHO WITHOUIVO
N,S THE MISINFORMAON
THE
CONTINUED MISINFORMATION THAT
MPFOR.>>HAIRMA
ANYBAROUND OF FINANCIAL
FRD THD L FRAUD?ELT WE HAVE, WEE
L TASKURO FINANCINOFWENT
TOANRYON, I'LL C
G DILIGENTLY AIT.T MADEHOBLIC
E VIE CAN' MONEYNGHIGHLERNING O